well you're very close my friend alex
jones
finally addressed owen benjamin no oh
yes he did
today this is oh this is fresh from
today oh
this is fresh from today oh no so here
we go
i care about this country you understand
the threat to this nation
now if you go to some leftist church or
some leftist synagogue or some leftist
mosque you're gonna find
the scum of the earth that hate this
country
and hate the family and hate god who've
captured churches
who've captured churches and synagogues
to tell us there is no god the god damn
pain
god is dead because oh yeah he needs his
papers
it's unbelievable how much paper is on
that desk
and he is winding up and he has he has a
gabe hoffman level fire hazard going on
in his studio
sorry but i don't mean it right he does
they want to be god
so it's just not reality based
and so i challenge people out there that
attack me and i'm not responding to you
because your attacks hurt me
i'm responding because i know a lot of
you are just in your own form of group
psychosis group think
and you really attribute magical powers
to like their leprechauns or something
and but you you attack me because that's
the popular algorithm that the left
allows online
you got some anti-semitic alex jones
rant baby google
green lights you all the way you've got
some unity
situation like i promote google bans
your ass they don't want unity
i'm really trying to make things work
here but remember
the owen benjamins of the world talented
comedian nice guy i had on
until i found out he was saying germany
had a great leader in the early 40s
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
it wow a psychotic demon both my
grandfathers almost died fighting
and they saw the dead bodies they saw
the piles of dead people don't give me
that crap
yeah there was a lot of their bodies but
it was mostly russians but alex you also
you also over simplifying uh adolf
as a quote psychotic demon also yep
uh uh puts the world in danger of having
another
come about yeah you can't dismiss things
well they're just evil people you
if you can't understand how a man
can lead a nation to that point then
it's
then it could happen again that's all
i'm saying so
i hate when people go forever demon
people
you're like they were they were like
[ __ ] uh
haberdashers and and uh shoe repairmen
that were [ __ ] members of the
party it didn't it wasn't demon people
uh
so i i don't know i i hate when people
do that because it's like all right
you're gonna
you want to get another uh that's how
you get another hand
by going well at least we're good people
at least
we're using authoritarianism to impose
good happy funtime rainbow laws and
that's good
and you're like you know that's gonna
you're still doing
running on good time happy rainbow times
to defend owen for a little bit which is
actually way worse than defending him
to defend owen for a little bit he was a
good leader
if you were german no am i wrong no no
mike's saying something's wrong
the german people were prosperous for a
while for a minute
for a bit i'm not saying forever i'm not
saying forever
if they if he didn't get too big for his
brits to decide i gotta get into russia
we've been never gonna live living in a
different planet right now
yeah that's what i gotta say i disavow
uh what me slopez and i will not uh
i will not uh be associated or
affiliated with this
denying uh far-right
terrorism oh
[ __ ] sorry alex
that i'm censoring or i sold out no dude
you're on youtube
i'm not i'm under attack and banned
everywhere they've taken my bank
accounts away they're trying to shut us
down
right now i've been sued 20 something
times i'm on the front lines i'm
changing the world and our audience is
and people like oh and sit there and say
oh you know trump's great but oh jones
to sell it to israel no go after trump
then that you don't have the huevos
because the yeah now now to go on owen
for a second
to say alec trump is great but alex
jones has sold out to israel maybe he
has
but to pretend that trump has not
already
all up israel's ass is 100
[ __ ] uh wait until you see my statue
in golden heights it's gonna be
unbelievable it's gonna be the tallest
statue in the history of israel it's
going to be taller
than their wall so which we pay for
so the oppressed people of palestine can
see my face
poking over the wall disapproving of
them
he'll be scowling in the statue yes
golden heights will be
i'm sorry trump heights will be
the greatest neighborhood in the history
of the middle east
oh man wait till they fix the trump
strip
uh all of dane we better go save george
while we can owen's gonna lose his [ __ ]
over this oh he is
annie semites won't do it and i'm sorry
you're jewish you don't like your dad
owen
that was sorry you got daddy issues bro
daddy yes you've got any issues with my
dad
i love mom daddy that's right my dad was
a real man
tough man fought in the wars i don't
know which ones
but he fought in some wars please do my
favorite the hell have you done oh
no no there it is my god i love it you
want to come on down to texas boy
get beat up by five foot ten texas boy
and possible cia asset
but definitely the texas thing yeah
definitely the texas park a red-blooded
american
he never told me hey i'm english and
irish and scottish and american indian
that's who we are
he brought me up that we're americans we
believe in freedom
and that's what it came down to please
don't forget we're only here because of
your support
okay and that's you know then he goes
into a live read uh you hear that
you tall son of a [ __ ] come on down to
taxi town yeah
oh man remember when he was in love with
alex jones not even a month ago and
everything his everything he loves is
falling apart
he's he is isolated man come on come on
i want two more days